this lecture is part of a program of
intense
in critical theory which through a grand
fund at Yale University the critical
theory collective can bring theorists
for multiple seminars on their current
work we've had the look over the past
few days to think with Alan katsu Pankaj
to think through several logics that
seem to me the more I listen to her
vital for us yesterday the logic of the
real and the double today the logic of
sexual difference as she has developed
it and tomorrow the logic of apocalyptic
thinking I want to thank her for coming
and sharing so patiently and openly her
most meticulous most expansive and most
rigorous dialectic alinka coupon church
is a researcher at the Slovenian Academy
of Sciences and arts a member of the
Ljubljana School for psychoanalysis and
a lecturer at the European Graduate
School she describes herself in a really
singular way as a Lakhani and
philosopher and social theorist the
general nouns philosopher and theorist
singular eyes by adjectives Lacan Ian
and social but just as importantly I
think the adjectives are radically
expanded by the nouns into a daring
proposition if flick-on ian
psychoanalysis could be a mode of
philosophizing it would become a theory
of the social this is I think the wager
of professor to poncho cheese writing
which has crystallized into several
important and well-known books I will
give the titles of the English
translations although so appeared in
Slovenian and many had been translated
into other languages as well starting in
about 2000 we received like gifts the
ethics of the real content lock on the
shortest shadow Nietzsche's philosophy
of the to why psychoanalysis three
interventions the odd one in on comedy
and most recently what is sex
which sounds like a joke but isn't some
elements of which were under heavy
discussion in the seminar today the
titles of her books should give you a
sense of the risk that philosophy and
psychoanalysis are thrown into in her
work maybe no other Lakhani and writes
about Nietzsche I heard her say this
offhand yesterday but you learn in
reading her Nietzsche book that
Nietzsche might be needed to make some
of lakhan's insights
human subjectivity into ontological
claims this is directly I think her
project to take psychoanalysis beyond
where it is sometimes comfortable in the
consultation room the theory book or the
classroom that is in the realm of
self-knowledge as a tool for potentially
better self-knowledge she takes it with
help from Nietzsche at one moment now
through sex also not so long ago through
comedy to a principle of the way things
are an ontology our problem is not that
we can only know ourselves through a
glass darkly so to speak but that we are
this glass and everything we do is riven
by its two sides as is the social field
this thought is tremendously powerful
too for taking account of one experience
in particular what professor Suppan
church calls ontological ambiguity the
sense that although you are called this
and that you do not identify completely
with this or that indeed you cannot
because your being what you are is split
doubled and non coincident with itself
you might say how can I live this way
this is a joke and yes
soup on Church is a fervent proponent of
jokes and she's also a great connoisseur
you'll probably hear some tonight the
books are full of them and they seem to
be a form of speech that is in
solidarity with this split state one
terrific joke in the sex book goes I
don't know where it's from she quoted it
in seminar quote there are no cannibals
here we ate the last one yesterday
clearly the cannibals are opaque to
themselves they don't know themselves
well enough to see that their full
bellies are exactly the sign of their
can ability that's not a word DuPont
which uses this joke to illustrate
something else a very complex negation
system in Lakhani and logic but it also
illustrates or embodies the strange
ontological given she's been working on
for many years that being accountable is
precisely what you feel this loss of
identity and anxiety over your place in
the delay between having eaten your
friend yesterday and maybe perhaps
eating
the one tomorrow that might be why they
or we need to eat another in the first
place
this may not be the moment to invite you
to the reception after the talk but I do
and there will be one if I've given you
the smallest hint of the complexity and
charm of these systematic and funny
philosophical books I will be glad for
more I encourage those of you who
haven't read them to read them tonight
professor - Pankaj will give a lecture
entitled after the end of art Hegel with
Francis Bacon let's welcome her thank
you very much Paul thank you all for
coming and I really would like to stress
how sincerely honored and happy I am to
be able to be here this week - to kind
of share my theory as you put it with
with the group in the seminar as well as
here today it is evening and to
emphasize that I really think how
extraordinary important the thing that
you are doing with this critical theory
initiative is I think it's really one of
the extremely important also if you
bought political act in the times that
we live in and it has bearings I think
much beyond the the simple limits of the
academic discussion so really thank you
very much so ok my talk today will be me
mostly on Francis Bacon not so much full
of jokes actually some pictures will be
replacing them I will talk on bacon I'm
not as you've also said I'm philosopher
whatever Lacanian philosopher obviously
I'm not art theorist I don't pretend to
approach this in this way I will
approach it bacon in my own particular
way and a very important part of this
way will be
looking at the bacons theory or if you
want philosophy namely a dis famous
interviews that David Sylvester made
with him over to more than two or three
destinies from 62 to 86 which were
published for the first time in 75 and
then there were subsequent edition with
a couple always setting couple of new
interviews added and for me this this
really was a kind of discovery a kind of
extremely fascinating thing to read and
I think it's it is of great importance
also it has a great philosophical
interest they have the interviews it's
not simply explaining his art he thinks
the way he thinks art and thinks about
what he is doing it's extremely precise
and articulated in ways that for me
resonate that in and this is a kind of a
surprising resonance probably with
certain things
from Hegel and this will be my starting
point so kind of showing this or why do
I think so in a mostly focusing on bacon
of course okay so let me introduce this
Hegelian aspect as you know of course in
his lectures on on aesthetics Hegel
famously concluded that art has reached
its end or most more precisely debt it
is for us a thing of the past this is
the exact quote he doesn't use the word
end and it is most interesting and
perhaps also surprising to see to what
extent Higa's account of what this
actually means what he means by this
rhymes with Bacon's view of the
situation in which according to him
modern artists find themselves and I
will read to you a quote from the
interviews this is bacon now he says I
think we are in a very curious position
today because when there is no tradition
there were two extreme ends there is
direct reporting like something that's
very near to a police report and then
there is only the attempt to make great
art and what is called the in-between
art really in the time like ours does
not exist
end of quote now which for me was quite
surprising and impressive is that Hegel
uses almost the same terms when he
describes how at the end of a romantic
art which he also considers to be the
culminating point of the movement in
which art kind of frees itself from all
prescriptions in regard to artistic
content in form that is prescriptions
springing from different traditions
precisely so art finally becomes free of
all these prescriptions related to
tradition but at that precise moment
Hegel says art kind of falls apart or
disintegrates into two extremes so now a
brief quote from Hegel he says in the
course of romantic art disposition
developed up to the point at which we
had to arrive at an exclusive interest
either in contingent contingent
externality or an equally contingent
subjectivity now what does this mean
Hegel relates the former that that is
this objective extreme in art so to say
today as he puts it imitation of
external objectivity in all its
contingent shapes that is too meticulous
kind of naturalist reproduction or
recording and reporting to use Bacon's
vocabulary from the previous quote of
what is let say out there and he Higa
relates the other extreme this
liberation of subjectivity in accordance
to its inner contingency to what he
calls humor
but one has to point out that humor
delayed and does not refer for Higa
simply to something like hilarious jokes
but simply to the fact that what is
primarily on display in this kind of art
that he associates with humor in late
romanticism is not this or that object
but the witness that the dis period the
cleverness the genius of the subject or
artists herself so in other word humor
does not stand here for a lady with his
subject making jokes about various
things including herself but whatever
material that is being treated in in
this way this material is not the
subject matter or the content of this
art it is not what is on display in it
what is on display is actually the humor
the witness itself claims here that is
to say precisely the subject so it is in
this sense it is subjective the subject
does not simply joke about things the
subject is the joke and Haggar actually
uses this quite ingenious expression
that which the Subic this he says there
is again a very short quote the artist
does therefore not produce a finger new
start but the subject makes itself seen
or displays itself the subject nor zzip
to them and what shows itself are the
feeling sensations the joke of the
subject so you see we have like here in
Higa on the one hand this kind of a
willful disappearance of the subject in
the attempt to do nothing but record
things as realistically not
realistically as possible like one
extreme art and on the other hand we
have what ultimately boils down to
displaying the artistic genius itself
that is to the so attempt to make great
art to use
what as bacon puts it almost 150 years
later so you see that it's I think it's
quite interesting how they put things
almost in the literally same terms okay
so I started with this resonance
surprising echoing between Higa and
bacon yet this Eric not wins
notwithstanding we cannot of course
ignore the fact that between Hegel and
bacon something did happen and something
that pushed so to say the Hegelian
dissolution of art into two extremes
over its edge we could say and bacon
relates the same thing to the discovery
of photography in a sense photography
with it with its capacity to record and
report precisely closed off the
objective extreme of art like took it
over when eventually and left only one
way for art to continue namely following
precisely this subjective path as hen's
Bacon's suggestion that contemporary art
is all about it attempt to make great
art now just a brief note I don't have
time to go into did but this of course
does not mean that for bacon photography
can be reduced to this that photography
is just about recording fact so it can
be much more than this and he actually
uses this as to it as you probably know
very much in his own art but there is
just this point that there is a certain
dimension of this recording reporting
which makes no sense in this way anymore
because of photography kind of occupies
this place you can do it better okay
let's move on so Blake as dismissive
views on abstract art are also a guest
very well known
he's quite combative and critical and
provocative in this
confrontation but again what is perhaps
less known or less emphasized is the
properly kind of dialectical even a
Guinean way in which he formulates this
abuse and here is again a quote from the
interviews he says one of the reasons
why I don't like abstract painting or
why it doesn't interest me is that I
think painting is a duality and that
abstract painting is an entirely
aesthetic thing it always remains on one
level it is only interested in the
beauty of its patterns and its shape or
its shapes we know that most people
especially artists have large areas of
an undisciplined emotion and I think
that abstract artists believed that in
this mark that they are making they're
catching all these sorts of emotions but
I think that quote in that way they are
too weak to convey anything I think that
great art is deeply ordered I think it's
a kind of yeah I think it's an nice
interesting quote so what is this
duality that painting is for bacon in
which accounts for the tangent that
makes it captivating that makes its
trunk according to him it is the tension
or the duality between precisely what he
calls recording or the illustration or
thing and something else more or
whatever in this sense for bacon del
it's a traditional old painters were
indeed lucky because they were born in
into the world where they were expected
to do the recording this illustration of
thing they thought that they were
recording and of course they did
something very much more than just
recording they at least some of them
produced artistic masterpieces
yet the
kind of inevitability on a necessity of
recording was crucial
according to bacon also for traditional
painters their artistic freedom and what
they produced on top of the recording
was kind of inseparable from the belief
that they or the yet this imperative did
they need that they had to record things
also illustrating this particular sense
and so things no longer stand this way
as I said before mechanical means of
recording starting with photography have
taken over this is a quote from bacon
the illustration a thing that painters
in the past believed they had to do and
then bacon kind of further speculate
it's a kind of a possible pair of how he
thinks that abstract painters think he
says that abstract painters realizing
this have thought why not just go on in
a free fancy way throughout all
illustration in all forms of recording
and just give the effect of form and
color okay it goes without saying that
this particular phrasing of what
abstract painters thought is about all
in the service of Bacon's particular
argument that he's making contrasting he
wants to contrast precisely what he sees
as this kind of a free fancy play with
something that he conceives as a deeper
necessity and tangent that gets lost in
this move if I was simply kind of give
him here so it is also clear of course
that for bacon this deeper necessity and
tangent or duality cannot be simply
regained by going back or ignoring
precisely the historical break of
modernism in all its aspects including
technological ones it cannot be gained
by it by saying ok let's continue to
record things and in this way the
will perhaps reappear until perhaps
produce something more unexpected or
captivating now baker's ass room was
different it was to shift the very focus
of recording without the dismissing it's
imperative this is how I would put it
and I will even with paintings and with
quotes try to argue for this and I think
this is precisely what makes him so
interesting the imperative to record has
changed recording is no longer about
what artists are expected to do or what
they think they have to do even if they
do something more or else it is about
one could even formulate it in this way
what about what they really have to do
in Bacon's word for this new type of
necessity is obsession he uses this word
several times
let me being stuck with something in
life in reality in others that you
absolutely want to record yet still have
to find a way of the coordinate of doing
it again quote from Bacon abstract
painting hasn't worked out because it
seems the obsession with something in
life that you want to record gives a
much greater tension and a much greater
excitement then when you've simply said
you just go on in a free fancy way and
record the shapes and colors you know
it's it's again the same kind of
argument there is certain obsession with
something that you absolutely want to
record so the obsession is the key term
here obsession with something you want
to record and not simply the recording
itself perhaps you get stuck in wanting
to record make a pure a singular thing
that strikes you in something this at
least is the imperative kind of Drive
that was there
for bacon when he painted the ad very
extreme of subjectivity like this
obsession and darkness with something
are kind of subjective modes there
emerges a kind of new and perhaps
surprising dimension of object this kind
of absolute necessity activation of of
doing it so I want to record an image is
is a phrase a sentence that bacon
repeats at many points in during this
interviews I wanted to record an image
which is a kind of a interesting say to
thing to say for a modern painter but
what is this image what is the status of
this image or appearance as you also
term state appearance obviously it is
not simply out there to be properly
recorded things or let's say people
appear all the time I can record how
people look or appear to me but how can
I record how they really appear this is
a kind of a phantom of this question
that disturb for for Baker so this image
this particular image that he wants to
record I would say it's not a natural
appearance it can only be a made
appearance and again this is his term
these are his terms an artifice which
renders that in reality which cannot be
seen in a direct way yet which we
somehow immediately recognize as some
crucial element or aspect of this
reality and say yes that's it
or in the case of a portrait that's him
or her this is what kind of drives him
not bacon so you see there is a split
right there there is a speak between we
could say two kind of images there is
image okay as a resemblance illustration
and there is we could say an image that
helped me in the appearance of a person
something that I absolutely want to
convey record more clearly more exactly
more violently he says it is something
that we will be able to recognize
immediately when we see it but it's
still kind of waiting to appear properly
speaking it's not kind of there
perhaps we could say that it is somehow
like a ghost image and the term ghost
makes some sense in this context because
there is a persistent lack six Lexus in
break-ins interviews which rhymes
profoundly with the famous hamlet theand
dictum the the famous words that he
utters apropos of the mousetrap no the
the device set up to make a pure boat
Hamlet knows only from his father's
ghost precisely
he says the plays the thing wherein I'll
catch the conscience of the king it's
this mousetrap device or artifice that
should make a pure what this ghostly
knowledge is and the idea of setting a
trap that will capture the reel of some
situation occurs again and again in in
bacon in interviews it this is really
kind of again a reoccurring lexical he
says for instance it's really a question
in my case of being able to set a trap
with which one would be able to catch
the fact at its most living point like
an artifice which would bring in life in
a more violent way that by simply
immediately conveying or recording life
or another very short quote he says I
think the difference from direct
recording through the camera is that as
our as an artist you have to in a sense
set a trap by which you hope to trap
this living fact alive no it did so I
think it's interesting that the
to think about this what this trap and
we'll come back to it also a little bit
later so this question of the trap is
directly connected to two further
questions obviously the question of how
to record an image by means other than
illustration or mimetic depiction as
well as to a more general interrogation
of the status of appearance as such and
I will start with this later let a
letter a little bit hope not too much in
a discretion digression wise but I think
it's quite essential this is all about
as I said before making the appearance
again something that he repeats making
the appearance this is not meant in the
sense of pretense or deceit but
literally of working it making it like
handwork make the appearance work as
process and bacon has disingenuous
formulation he says the mystery of
painting today is how can appearance be
made it can be Illustrated it can be
photographed but how can this thing be
made so that you catch the mystery of
appearance within the mystery of making
okay it's a complicated quote but I
think it's quite ingenious it's how do
you catch the mystery of appearance
within the mystery of making look it is
about making of appearance which means
with means others then illustration
involving of obviously also this is his
words the whole questioning of what
appearance is so I think now just to
kind of break this speech a little bit
this quality of poor appearance is for
me at least this is how I see it
particularly striking in paintings like
the one we have here
we're bacon kind of produce a seat this
is how I sit as a result of a kind of
lack of depth of anything behind the
figure okay one can see it we were just
talking about it before with Paul as a
kind of decay but if you look
particularly the picture on the extreme
left I think this kind of absence of day
I mean it conveys for me for me this
idea of appearance that kind of stands
on its own but nevertheless has a
certain real so this is the triptych
from August 1972 and the one could
perhaps produce other examples but I
think it's a it's an interesting way of
Al for me it's kind of a reflection on
what is appearance and how to make this
mystery of appearance in the to appear
in the very mystery of creating again
perhaps surprisingly this idea of
appearance in this insistence resonates
strongly with what he does situate with
the way he goes situate what painting is
all about
throughout his lectures of the statics
namely shine on China usually translated
in English as pure appearance and also
showing sometimes see for pages and
pages he girl insist on how painting is
all about creating a pure appearance and
not about the appearance of disorder
thing and he meant he means this kind of
appreciate the obviously he says for
instance very short quote painting must
press on to the extreme of pure
appearance that is to say to the point
where the content does not matter and
when the chief interest is the artistic
creation of that appearance
you see it's a again for me this
resonates a lot with how bacon puts it
and for hingle shine is precisely a made
appearance in made in the same sense
that I was referring to before and also
what he calls an unsold appearance which
is a most interesting notion I think in
the kinkle explicitly states that what
is at stake here is not the conformity
of the painting with its object like the
object it represents but he says to show
the correspondence of the portrait
object with itself of the painterly
object with itself this is what is at
stake and this is said to be reality
insult for itself so incidentally but I
don't think accidentally bacon for his
part likes to speak about an image that
lives on its own that has a life of its
own and I think this is very much his
version of an insult appearance
precisely it relates directly to also to
another aspect of it that I will not go
into this familiar notion of objective
humor but anyway so the crucial point
here in this Guinean idea is the idea
that what is at stake is the kind of
correspondence or not of the portrait
object painterly object with itself and
I think that this idea can actually take
us very far in understanding how bacon
does and thinks art in the art for him
is not about how painter is affected by
different object simply how she sees
them and so on it is also not about
making an appearance of this real object
it is about making you could say
creating precisely a knob appearance as
object of how this object
really
to themselves in this precise sense it
is in this precise sense that appearance
is insult or has a life of its own so
again to cut this a little bit with
appearances with pictures I think this
could be a way of seeing or
understanding Bacon's propensity for
series you know the there is this there
are all these paintings that begin with
titles like three studies particularly
triptychs but there are three studies
were simply series of paintings so there
is this tendency to to produce to paint
series of paintings and I think this can
be related to what I just said about
this logic of appearance and the
painterly objects relating to each other
and creating the real of it of what it
is about with precisely within this
movement so this is one example and I
will then explain more what I think
about it very briefly but still three
studies for portrait of Henrietta
mariah's this is from 63 then I have
another one from a later period which is
three studies for self for self
portraiture
which again has this for me this kind of
aspect of appearance
what exactly is appearance for this
purpose that I was referring to to
before so it cannot be kind of good
examples of both so these paintings are
these appearances do not tell a story
bacon is very much insisting on this
when he talks about precisely he's asked
about why he paints this why series why
there are several paintings it's not
about telling a story but what does this
mean I think it means that we are not
dealing with kind of a temporal
sequence and with narrating some
segments of reality but precisely with
the constellation where one picture
reflects on other on the other
continuously and this is from bacon one
picture reflects on the other
continuously so figures in the series do
not exactly we could say relate to each
other day in a sense they are in a sense
the same painterly object which relates
to itself through this serie structure
so it's not between them there is this
kind of it's it's like one split in
three which moves or split or whatever
in three forms it which kind of moves
around and produces a certain movement
within itself so and it is only through
this relation relates to itself through
this area structure that the painterly
object actually becomes what it is or
appears it only appears is created in
this very process so that this cereal or
tripartite structure is one of the ways
I think in which painterly object
related to themselves and in doing this
kind of trap and convey the real they
want to record there is a kind of a
construction going on with the Surrey
ality as a way for some real to kind of
return to its place or find its place in
it okay and this consideration will now
lead us to measure and this went to the
concluding part and not not immediately
concluding but the second last part to
measure not only the proximity but also
the distance between giggling Baker
obviously as I already said before there
is something like a historical event
reality of which Hegel could not have
any idea and I think it would be very
non Hegelian to claim otherwise so I'm
not simply saying bacon is all there in
Hagar or disease to please and the same
thing
there is something which in fact does I
think separate them although it's still
eliminating to think about this
precisely through Hagar like pushing
this Hegelian edifice kind of over its
edge so bakers are as well as his
reflections on art forced to distinguish
forces to distinguish between two things
which are often taken together or
confused I think one is the question of
resemblance of recognition of recording
of recording and the other the second is
the question of illustration or
illustrative and non illustrative form
and as I've already tried to emphasize
the first the question of resemblance
recognition recalling recording remains
absolutely valid even imperative for
bacon one doesn't just go and display
one's feelings on the canvas one doesn't
present the onlooker with kind of a soup
of feelings and sensations that the
later can enter and be captivated by I
have an interesting quote here but
perhaps we'll can come back to this in
the discussion painting is an artifice a
deeply ordered and disciplined form that
works on feelings but not simply with
feelings a form for bacon that unlocks
as he puts it different layers of
sensation and abstract expressionism is
on the other side for bacon as a kind of
running subjective commentary and
exposition of how things make us feel
this is how he kind of
recordings of our sensation whereas keys
insert of form that or a finger that
could unlock simultaneously different
layers of sensation be more kind of
violent in this in this sense also more
competitive one aims here at some sort
of recognition at producing the effect
of es debt it with the kind of paintings
but this recognition is not based on
what we would call illustration as and
of point-by-point correspondence it can
come from an image that looks very much
distorted for instance bacon says what I
want to do is to distort the thing far
beyond the appearance but in the
distortion to bring it back to a
recording of the appearance no there's
this kind of movement in in relation to
this last quote I think the first thing
perhaps not to do is to take this
distortion which is obviously very much
present in bacon to take this distortion
itself as an illustration or as a
metaphor of say the distorted world that
we live in and actually after the end of
the world bacon first exhibited the
probably most famous three studies four
figures and the base of a crucifixion
from forty four this interpretation is
precisely what happened it also to some
extent what made him famous that namely
the deformity was kind of generally seen
perceived as in a way reflecting the
horrors of the world and this kind of
and bacon was very much opposed to this
reading and I think very rightly so
because what he was after here when I
think much deep
then this kind of psychology the world
was shattered and in its foundation and
the question is not it cannot be how do
we feel about it but rather how does
this affect our rate or capacity one of
feeling and perception itself in its own
ontological core how does this affect
the way we can recognize record recall
things at all so something has changed
in the very mode in which the word or
spirit or life appears to itself or can
appear to itself who just simply appear
something has changed in the words mode
of relation to itself so this is why the
painter as part of this relation it has
obviously to change her way of doing art
but this is not simply about choosing
more macabre objects and motives like
the one that yeah abandoning bacon like
crucifixion meat screams and so on but
it's also about the way in which objects
now relate to themselves correspond to
themselves across a violent interruption
of all immediacy precisely in this
relation and I think this is the this is
the violet point it's not and he also
kind of exists he doesn't want to accept
this idea that David Sylvester also kind
of suggests that his paintings are like
there is this horror there is this
Wireless at all he really doesn't want
to go there and kind of endorse this
it's not not there that the violence is
situated in like the motifs
painting the flesh to the meat and so on
for him this is beautiful it's not
horrible but again and I will try to
explain this what I mean by this violent
interruption
okay so I said that what what happens is
now that the object they can only relate
to themselves or correspond to
themselves as I said before this
painterly object across this violent
interruption of all immediately
immediacy in this relation and for me
for instance an example of this of how
he how this is part of the way he makes
his art his Bacon's insistence that he
prefers to make portrait based on
photography's of his models people whom
he knew otherwise but when he painted
them their portraits he preferred to do
it from photographer photography's
rather than to have these models like
posing directly and the way he explains
this is he says the only thing that can
bring about the real recognition is an
artifice now that is to say an image
with absolutely no immediate like direct
or organic whatever links with the model
whereas this is quote the real model
before you in my case inhibits the
artificiality by which this thing can be
brought back or recollected so in other
words you see that there is this
interesting paradox that actually
interacting with a live person with this
life sitting for you kind of inhibit the
artifice which can bring real life into
the image know that their life is here
on two different levels and he goes for
this other kind of interrupts way where
also as we will see this idea of the
trap comes in okay so bacon sustained
against illustration is so much part of
the I think predominant way in which we
in which modern art thinks itself or
about itself the
we risk missing bacons
exceptionality here namely precisely the
fact that for bacon distant against
illustration is absolutely bound up with
the seemingly contrary imperative of
recalling recording recognition of
recording of an image of the coincidence
or correspondence of the painterly
object with itself so this imperative is
something that he will never give up
because it is the very generator of the
tangent that for him makes the art
interesting and powerful so the
fundamental opposition or difference
here is rim between illustrative and non
illustrative form this is where now
things get also very interesting
conceptually and this in turn relates to
what bacon calls a logical outcome and
an illogical way of getting to it in the
processes in which he works he wants to
do a portrait of a person but not by
copying her threat he has to do it yet
he also has to do it in a completely
illogical way that is without there
being any kind of direct continuity
between this person or this object in
the appearance and the whole question
becomes how I know what I want to do but
I don't know how to bring it about he
keeps repeating again this is one of the
phrases that keeps returning in the
whole walking process is about that and
this the famous in famous chance that he
talks about it that I will now focus on
a little bit like simply throwing paint
at the picture hoping for some
accidental way of finding out how to do
it enters precisely here
sometimes when he throws paint an
accidental mark appears the trenders
perfectly or shows him a way to go about
it
what he wants to record he kind of
recognize it without this coming from an
kind of illustrative descriptive
activity and when this happens the
effort must be he's a debt of
inevitability not simply of some free
fancy freedom so again we have this
seemingly contradiction aliy mode in
which he puts it in other words the idea
would be this you are obsessed with
something you want to record you paint
and draw paint not working by means of
illustration you work in a totally
illogical way but when you succeed the
thing is quote totally real and in the
case of a portrait totally recognizable
as the person so it's this kind of so
the only way to the logical outcome is
the illogical way of going about it
otherwise logic itself relating of the
object to itself is kind of lost in
translation it is lost in illustration
in copying loses its vigor and becomes
something else more or less an exotic
okay what exactly is going on here this
would be my kind of last question and I
will try to make some sense of it why
this insistence on resemblance that is
not brought about by an effort to create
resemblance but by means of illogical
non-voluntary non-represented
representational Marx actually marked
that he for instance recognizes already
in Rembrandt he says the way Rembrandt
portraits like eye sockets and stuff
it's precisely not that you can see mark
that are there precisely in this way not
in an illustration way this is why
Rembrandt is one of his kind of big
idols so why does one what does one gain
but no
by not doing it logically there are two
answers I think are better two steps in
answering this question first the
results the image it's much more
powerful in this way
bacon is convinced of it it can in one
can see the difference actually if this
succeeds and it works like this it kind
of gets to you in on another level then
what through this kind of more
representative illustration away and the
other step or part of the answer is
simply one cannot do it the old way any
longer not simply because photography
and other available means of technical
production reproduction have cut off
this path for art but because more
importantly the illogical Proceedings
preceding marks precisely an interaction
a discontinuity a gap that is essential
I think this is how I understands Reed
bacon here that essential to the new
logic of appearance as such precisely
understood as the coincidence in the
very difference of the object appearance
with itself and of course this
coincidence is far from obvious or
necessary so I think it is here at this
point that the whole idea which is so
central for bacon of the accident you
know that he was also a passionate
gambler the moment he sought a picture
he went I don't know to Monte Carlo and
kind of gamble so the the question of
chance is very important for him also in
this level and what he called a guided
chance again a short quote I want a very
ordered image but I wanted to come about
by chance the same kind of dedication so
the idea says bacon would really be just
to pick up a handful of paint and throw
it at the canvas in hope that the
portrait was there this is
and I think we can have from this quote
this idea of a kind of radical
discontinuity precisely or severus of
all and of organic links at the very
core of of your object in its
ontological Constitution as appearance
throw something and the appearance is
there yet by saying that this would be
his idea I don't think that bacon has in
my mind a kind of unattainable ideal but
rather something like perhaps his
version of the end of art namely this
would be the painting to put an end to
painting as art because what art as
practice consists of according to bacon
is precisely the work the dedication the
passion that makes this happen it brings
about this the quiz he does from the
very discontinuity the world that brings
about the Queen this craziness of the
object with itself from the thin this
discontinuity or as a form of this very
discontinuity if this work were no
longer necessary then we could say
perhaps there would be no room or need
for art so so did chance this accident
only becomes chance and this is
important for bacon when you spot it and
size it sees it that is when you are
able to see in the strange thing that
just happened when you did some
something this happened out there when
you recognize a surprising match with
what you want to recorder or surprising
way in which you the chose you how to do
what you want to do it didn't know how
now you have a way at least an
indication of it and the work of the end
the art proper only we could say begins
when something like this happens and
quote again it has to do with using your
critical faculty where you suddenly see
an
opening so there is this idea of there
is a certain opening something happens
here you use your critical need your
critical faculty to recognize it because
obviously Daniel Silvester asks him at
some point okay if you're whatever
cleaning lady would just throw paint
would this be the same thing I mean yes
and no I think for him it's not he's not
and I will insist on this he's not just
saying this is not about throwing paint
and seeing what happens and then
preserving let's say aesthetically
interesting result it's not at all about
this bacon doesn't want to his images
even to look like thrown paint he he is
quite explicit on this point he want
them to look inevitable and kind of
bring on precisely this idea this
obsession this something that he wants
to do to record so this is not with all
these insistence on our important role
of the accident of the chance in his
discourse on this it is not about
glorifying simply the accident accident
as say the spontaneous or the
unconscious or whatever it is about a
very disciplined selection which only
works with things or accidents that
enable him to record the image he wants
to record it is not about preserving
displaying the accident but more about
kind of using it putting it in the
service of of some necessity of some
obsession like a way out precisely like
an opening what one wants to record and
I think this is what he calls chance in
this strong sense and or guided change
which is again this kind of paradoxical
notion it has a lot to do with luck
obviously with something that happens
something that unexpectedly and quite
literally enters the picture but it has
at least as much to do with the ability
to recognize what happened there just
not simply didn't do it
out of the artistic work to recognize
what happened there and that it did
happen one thing it to happen in being
able to also dismiss discard the rest as
you probably know bacon was quite famous
for allegedly throwing away destroying a
lot of good pictures even once they've
already sold very well so it was he had
this tendency to say this this is too
went too far so he would immediately
destroy it so it is about recognizing
the right accident using that accident
working in a most disciplined way to do
with its help what you want to do it is
also a wave one could say of making
something substantial emerge out of this
contingency which is basically let's
take here so you throw paint or other
staff and something happens you use it
to work your way back to the appearance
you want to make to do the pearance in
this sense that I defined before the
image or object you kind of want to
record so again this going out like
throwing out and then working your way
back is kind of deeply Hegelian move yet
I would say radicalize here by an
element of we could say pure
discontinuity in Hegel it seems at least
according to predominant critical
accounts of him we in Ljubljana have
some different ideas about this but
nevertheless the predominant critical
account of Hegel is that the spirit goes
out of itself alienates from itself and
loses itself in the other only then to
come back to itself as if logically
necessarily from within this experience
of losses is a kind of the electrical
move which yeah it's there in Hegel and
I would say that what is different now
in bacon or what he kind of wants to
enforce with how he does things
is that there is absolutely no necessity
no logic anymore no guarantee that the
spirit will find itself again it can
simply stay out of itself
wandering indefinitely in this ghostly
form in the form of a ghost image
I think Baker's implicit thesis is that
it can only happen that it finds itself
again it is a question of chance
precisely and of art which is this kind
of guided chance and we could perhaps
say again using this bacons opposition
that he likes to use differently from
abstract expressionism which contains
itself with recording these ecstatic
forms of the spirit it's falling out of
itself and kind of airing around in its
ghostly form bacon kind of wants to
bring it back to itself he wants for it
to find its figure we could say and with
it of course the very itself to which it
has to return this itself it's not
simply somewhere in hiding but has to be
actually invented created in this very
movement we could say the point is
precisely to create in the appearance
itself the thing that his appearance
resembles recalls but which is not
simply it has a certain dimension of the
real so when he speaks and I am really
very close enough to concluding when he
speaks of the appearance of how this
mystery of the painting is how can
appearance be made I think we could say
he speaks precisely of the figure of the
famous Bacon's figure and here I would
go perhaps a little bit against the very
very interesting and productive reading
the
for instance de leurs has a bacon I
think there is nothing which is
basically the he makes the figure
explode precisely by finger that uses
figure in order to explode the figure
which I think it's the most Hegelian
formulation one can find the loss is
sometimes much more directly Couvillion
that he would like to be but I propose a
slightly different reading here I think
there is first of all there is nothing
obvious let a lot alone easy in making
proposing a figure today because if what
has no figure and uncountable images of
people objects landscapes whatever that
we are sank into thanks to whatever
visual media and so on there are not
really figures in this strong bacon Ian
sense the most often recall nothing real
or or around hardly so that perhaps we
could say that figuration also in the
classical this strong but also classical
painterly sense of the term does not
really need to get exploded it already
has exploded and the effort is rather
the opposite it is a kind of a task to
make to make a figure to bring about a
genuine figure and I think this is the
dis interesting tension that bacon talks
about in which kind of drives his work
and particularly in his early work it is
often quite striking how we have this
idly this is just a way of seeing this
but how figures literally kind of strive
to appear to form themselves out of and
what is often a very dense net of
abstract patterns and I have like three
its obviously cannot be reduced this but
I have like three I think very direct
examples of this this one is a study for
portrait from 49 this is the famous
study after
asked us from 1950 and again study after
will ask us portrait of Pope Innocent 10
it's 53 so yeah you see this kind of
attention if you want or struggle at
work here in the de stake of of the
figure and the whole reflection of what
is within it so we could tell and now
this is really the end there is a
fundamental discontinuity but there
remains attention and at stake is the
inscription I would say for bacon of
this radical discontinuity and not
simply explosion of all continuty
because it's a different logic if you
inscribe and discontinuity is here in
the world tension and because of it or
we could say discontinuity appears for
all the more violently because there is
coming back a recalling a creation of
recognizable appearance discontinuity is
there because something is returning to
its place and discontinuity is
observable precisely at the moment
stunting returns to its place and not
simply perhaps while it's kind of
wandering around so in this sense
recognition I think itself is a surprise
or rather it is the surprise what is
surprising is that we recognize
something at all okay I think in this is
precisely in this sense that bacon will
say with humor okay I will finish with
something that sounds like a joke but I
think it's not he will save it humor but
also quite sincerely I'm always
surprised when I wake up in the morning
even what is more most obvious there is
this element of discontinuity at work in
it and the surprise that accompanies it
okay this is it basically thank you very
much
oh yes I think I couldn't take a gap
between the kind of quartz it's been a
longer day effort so it's because of Big
Love yes as the figure sort of being a
birth out of this surrounding
abstraction I wonder if we could return
to the first image you showed the way
before very first good I think it might
be doing something a little bit
different it strikes me as very witty
series of images particularly in its
differentiation of planes mm-hmm because
particularly on the left and the right
it looks like the figure is sort of
posed in a traditional kind of posture
for portrait photography and I think
that's emphasized by the black campus
what could be construed as a black
campus behind him maybe something like a
photograph but then the sort of spill of
blood or paint is on a different plane
that sort of resembles the plane of
abstract expressionism Holland framed in
dollars for more paintings or you know
even Jackson Pollock strip paintings and
it seems like it's sort of a witty
separation of this idea of illustration
versus abstraction but then abstraction
the sort of paint and the blood is
coming out of the figure and that may be
the moment of capture of the figure is
actually sort of the moment that the
mechanism of painting or of this
artistic dialectic that you're
constructing is sort of revealed in
painting itself mm-hmm so that the
capture of the figure is the Berthe
process and I wonder if maybe these
these images are actually sort of doing
the philosophical legwork maybe even
more poignant Lee than then he
constructs in his interviews no this is
a this is a very ingenuous remark no I
very much I think it's
second way of formulating what is going
on and also there is at some point in
the interviews when he speaks precisely
of how obviously he does use the the
abstraction in a certain way it's not
that he wants I mean he uses it in a way
that brings something else out I mean
just what you as you said so I think
it's also obviously I mean I think if
one would have to decide probably one
could say that he was a even better
painter that he was a philosopher
materials but so I am absolutely
convinced that there are ways I mean I
don't know I really started to work with
the the words with the the interview to
kind of even find a way of also perhaps
some artifice to look to the pictures in
a way that would not be some kind of
attempt a direct commentary but I think
for somebody who is as a gas perhaps
probably you are much more trained in
this I think this is a way I mean
obviously the paintings the pictures
themselves are reflection precisely are
they I mean this thought process is
built into them and it's and this is
also what makes it so powerful I think
it yeah thanks those very interesting I
have two questions or two suggestions
for contrast I think both are directed
at maybe hearing some more about the
role that the real has in the paintings
understanding of bacon glass and let's
use to contrast so I very much like the
description that you gave of the of the
series and Baker in which the picture
articulates it serves as a continuous
reflection upon itself mm-hmm
so one way of thinking about this could
be that somehow art is very self
referential it just returns one dose of
pure appearance it's not about
the thing anymore depicted but just it
circles around itself if you describe it
like then it seems it becomes look seems
to look similar to other understandings
of modernism just returns to its own
yeah but it seems to be something else
that's going on and I would be
interested here here some more about
this relation that this type of self
reference has maybe to the wheel and
another suggestion in the same direction
so you were describing the the role that
chance has and also the kind of
inevitability of the product
now we could relate this to to a certain
kind of understanding that we find in
content and that hiegel also adopts in a
certain manner so the artwork appears as
natural and then Hegel heads that it's
important that's not just appears is not
sure but it's made natural so that's the
great thing about the artwork but still
there's a certain sense in which it's a
kind of a traditional requirement that
the product of art should have a natural
appearance should be some sort of a
second nature but now it seems to me
that the kind of chance and
inevitability that you're tracing there
is something else so it's not just a
product of spirit then the P is natural
again that doesn't strike us in but
another form of inevitability and so my
sense is again that's something that
could be explained in terms of the real
so yeah just about kind of contrasting
cases that might help us to narrow this
down yeah thank you very much no I hope
I will be I'm still focused enough to
answer this question because it's
absolutely crucial and it I brought in
this term of the real which I'm kind of
working with and on much more in detail
in in the seminar which is the real that
is not simply equivalent or synonymous
with with reality or like the object in
this kind of immediate everyday sense of
the world and I think that to some
extent we can say for for all art not
only
Modern Art that it actually has whenever
it is kind of strong and will art that
it has this kind of dimension of drill
which is not reducible to the the the
simple
what is it makes art art it is not the
resemblance with the with whatever the
even in the kind of traditional art it
is always the genetic something more
then reveals precisely this reality in a
way that is new and that enables to
enables okay enables makes it possible
for a subject to to conceive this a kind
of a as a kind of an with a new object
so there is a certain objective
dimension which is not reducible to
reflection of the objectivity there but
which emerges with the very subjective
take on this particular reality but
which is nevertheless and so then it's
the Co question of the real end of what
art what is that we recognize and there
is obviously this Keynesian questioning
there how does it happen that even
though we have no firm a priori criteria
about what is art how to arrest B how to
make art we nevertheless recognize it
when we when we see so it's not it's as
he put it
universality without a concept it's not
that we have a pre-established concept
and it we apply it and we see okay that
it it kind of be only from each work of
art we learn what the art what is the
object this I think is the the real the
dimension of the real that that I'm
talking about or at least one part of it
another way of putting it would be as
you rightly remarked this relating of
the the question of the serious and
relating of the paintings among
themselves or it's not about self
referentiality it's not simply about
this
triple together it's just reflecting
upon itself it is precisely about
certain the things can only relate to
themselves across precisely a certain
discontinuity and this discontinuity
itself kind of appears as an object or
something as something real in the very
painting so that they are different I
mean I am NOT saying that there is one
way in which to describe or define this
real but basically for me real or is
precisely something about the situation
which is not simply or directly visible
in it but which nevertheless kind of not
really explains it but what kind of
gives us the the explains it in the
sense that we kind of know what is what
the the coordinates of it are and this
is why I like this sorry an image or of
the mousetrap from from Hamlet because
here you have this good image of a real
which can never be directly this is what
I think interesting really it's not
something some hidden reality that needs
to be revealed
it is only something that could be
constructed this is why it's only
possible to be there via read a blink of
fiction you know there is this mouse
it's a play within the play which will
catch the produce the real it's not that
simply it was harsh harsh it was hidden
but it's precisely that the very thing
the the core of how the Kingdom of
Denmark functions there is about this
crime but it's not that we can simply
say ah
let's eat food on it and eat it there is
the only way this is what I want to say
the only way not simply to reveal or
this real but to inscribe it in the very
reality of which it is the real is by
redoubling of fish by by artifice and I
think this is very much what is going on
here in
in bacon at least this is how I see it
yeah sorry it took me some time to get
on my toes I think I can take one more
question but then I'm not sure I think
it's me thank you so much for this
fascinating question the discussion of
Bacon's figure which is beyond the Sun
of its appearances I keep trying to
figure out right for this before first I
thought it was Heidegger the arts of
truth process which is not reducible to
either empirical inventories or
subjective gushing no it's Andre Besson
and the energy the photographic image in
which a true realism would not be
reducible to appearance would be
something else
I thought no people some people joke
that that title that that paper from
1945 should be called the oncology what
what I think this is about x-rays and
images which if you know what bacon was
deeply fascinating photograph is usually
lousy you're not going to illustrate a
matter with a photograph because you
can't see the structure and an x-ray
image is not going to be particularly
clear you need to have some kind of
expert knowledge to have to figure out
what's going on so I don't this is a
comment or question then just how would
me do you think that the anatomical
image or the x-ray radiograph is an
example of no I think it's a it's a very
good question and comment in the same
thing I think it's absolutely the right
question to ask and I think there is
something to it I don't have I would
have to think about it but it the drinks
really when you when you say that is
that the way that he used this this and
also some other it's one is the x-rays
and the other is which is I think
related perhaps also to this thing that
we were just discussing before the
serious
it's the the photography's of movement
or which kind of will break down the
movement into this in which is I guess
yeah the definitely yeah
related to - to what type of trying to
kind of formulate or or say here yeah
[Applause]
[Music]